since the advent of digital cameras
we've seen plenty of issues arise that
require new solutions yeah for example
when using a front of the lens neutral
density or ND filter on a digital camera
cinematographers notice curious effects
on the image further testing showed that
the effects were caused by infrared
contamination they needed a solution
many companies please read this in a
movie man voice because it sounds really
many companies offer new and detailed
terms with surface coatings that cut out
the evil wavelength wait however these
filters created distracting reflections
the team have been introduced to die
based in four I can't say I finished I'm
sorry and infrared neutral density
filter that solved both problems since
then other companies have created
similar versions but tiffin responded
first the last time the Academy handed
out this special plaque was in 2007 so
tonight marks a unique event to Steven
Tiffin Geoff Cowan and Michael fezzik
the Academy presents an award of
commendation for their pioneering and
timely work in developing the infrared
neutral density filter gentlemen
wow thank you
and that's my son third generation
Tiffin in the business v11 thank you so
we sincerely thank the members of the
Academy's scitech awards target
committee the main committee and the
Academy for bestowing this tremendous
honor upon us we proudly accept we
proudly accept this award of
commendation and honor the memory of my
father net Tiffin our company's founder
who instilled in each of us the passion
to listen to professional image makers
visual storytellers and help develop
products that help create the world's
greatest images on behalf of Jeff Cohen
I brother-in-law whose birthday it is
today and he's a New England Patriots
fan Mike Fezzik Mike fat cigar head
engineer the hundreds of tiffin
associates behind the scenes we stand
committed to continue to support this
industry that we love and we find it so
wonderfully pleasing that in this world
of digital technology this world of high
technology we're being given this great
honor for a wonderful piece of glass
thank you so much everyone good night